This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是数字“2”%，可以在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在“回顾过去”播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格里斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论20世纪80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。嘿，各位，最近怎么样？欢迎收听“艰难求知”，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位经验丰富的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须这样做。在iHeart无线电应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解“艰难求知”。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名男同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食其果。在iHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners. old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I would like to extend an official welcome to the final episode of 2024. And honestly, what a year it has been. Like what an insane, massive, phenomenal year for the podcast and for me as well. So I just want to start by expressing my gratitude and having a little quick chat about what we have done. The biggest thing for me this year was, of course, announcing my book, announcing that I wrote
欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20多岁时的心理学。我想正式欢迎大家收听2024年的最后一期节目。老实说，这一年过得真快。对于播客和我自己来说，这简直是一个疯狂、巨大、非凡的一年。所以我只想首先表达我的感激之情，并简单聊聊我们所做的事情。对我来说今年最大的事情，当然是宣布我的书，宣布我写了
a book basically based on this podcast called Person in Progress. And it does not pass me by a single day that there would be no way in this world that I would have had the opportunity to write that book without you guys, without the listeners. and the support that you have given me. And this year, so much of 2024 was focused on writing that book, making it the best possible, most scientific, most researched, but also personal vulnerable story that I could make it. And there were so many, like, long nights, you know, up to 1, 2 a.m.,
一本书，基本上是基于这个播客，名为《成长中的人》。每一天我都深刻地意识到，如果没有你们大家，没有听众，以及你们给予我的支持，我在这世上绝无可能获得写这本书的机会。今年，2024年的很大一部分时间都集中在写那本书上，使其成为尽可能最好、最具科学性、最具研究性，同时也最个人化、最脆弱的故事。而且有很多很多长夜，你知道的，一直熬到凌晨1点、2点，
waking up at 8 a.m. the following morning, working the whole day to write this book and make it good. and it was such an obsessive passion project for me that there is no way that it couldn't not define this year. And then next year is probably going to be defined by the fact that it's going to be released. It comes out in April 2025 and I feel like that's just going to be an equally surreal moment. But for now, I am just planning my feet where I am and reminiscing on what an insane journey that was, honestly, I was speaking to like my family about this today. I was like, I can't believe I wrote almost 100,000 words this year, plus every, all the other writing that I did for the podcast, but it was just such a mammoth exercise. Like it's, you know, there's just so many opportunities in this
第二天早上8点醒来，工作一整天来写这本书，让它变得更好。这对我来说是一个如此痴迷的激情项目，以至于它不可能不定义这一年。然后明年的特点可能就是它即将发行。它将于2025年4月上市，我觉得这也将是一个同样超现实的时刻。但现在，我只是立足当下，回味这是一段多么疯狂的旅程，老实说，我今天跟我的家人谈起这个。我说，我简直不敢相信我今年写了近10万字，再加上我为播客所做的所有其他写作，但这简直是一项庞大的工程。就像，你知道的，在这个中，有太多的机会
life where we really get to test ourselves and see how much we are capable of and how hard we can work. And so, you know, often we don't actually take those opportunities. Like, when was the last time you really tested yourself and gave yourself a real massive thing to work towards. And that was like something that I did this year. So I'm very, very proud of that. I'm very, very grateful for the opportunity. Another insane, crazy, beautiful thing we did this year was we held our first two meetups, our first two friendship meetups for the podcast. We had one in July in Sydney, which was the inaugural meetup. And it just went so well. if you attended, thank you for being my guinea pigs, but I also feel like we all had such an
生活中，我们真正去考验自己，看看我们有多大能力，能有多努力工作。所以，你知道的，我们往往并不真正把握那些机会。就像，你上一次真正考验自己并给自己设定一个真正巨大的目标是什么时候？这也是我今年做的事情。所以我非常非常为此感到骄傲。我非常非常感谢这个机会。今年我们做的另一件疯狂、美丽的事情是，我们举办了前两次聚会，为播客举办了前两次友谊聚会。我们在7月份在悉尼举办了一次，这是首场聚会。进展得非常顺利。如果你参加了，谢谢你当我的小白鼠，但我也觉得我们都度过了如此
amazing time. And then we held our second one in October, October? Yeah, October, in Melbourne. And that was just equally fulfilling. And actually, that was where I announced the book for the first time. So the people in that room, all 75 of them were the first ones to hear about it. My heart was so full after each of those experiences. So many, like hours. And I would say, say anxiety and stress went into creating them because I wanted it to be like value for money, but I also wanted to make sure that it was fun and that people really wanted to be there and got something out of it. And as soon as like I stepped into that room and you guys all started coming, I was like, wow, like this community is just like literally speechless to even try to explain
美好的时光。然后我们在10月份举办了第二次聚会，10月？是的，10月，在墨尔本。那同样令人感到充实。实际上，正是在那里我第一次宣布了这本书。所以房间里的那些人，全部75人是第一批听到这个消息的人。经历这一切后，我的内心充满了感动。有很多，比如小时。我想说，焦虑和压力都投入到了创建它们的过程中，因为我希望它物有所值，但我也想确保它是有趣的，人们真的想去那里并从中获得一些东西。一踏进那个房间，你们所有人开始涌来，我就想，哇，这个社区简直是……面对这些
the memory, like just beautiful, beyond beautiful, intelligent, kind, generous. Every single person who came to those meetups was like the most impressive. person, the most interesting person, the most creative person I had ever met. And that was just such a beautiful thing to be able to witness and to be able to bring everyone together. So if you were at one of those two meetups, thank you so much for coming along, even when there wasn't much like prior information about it. You really were the test subjects. But that means that next year, we will be doing 10 of those meetups, not just in Australia, but across the world. world. We're going to be starting in Canberra. We're going to do another one in Sydney,
记忆，简直无法用言语形容，简直是美丽，无比美丽，聪明，善良，慷慨。参加这些聚会的每一个人，都是最令人印象深刻的人，最有趣的人，我见过的最具创造力的人。能够见证这一切，并把大家聚在一起，是一件非常美好的事情。因此，如果你曾参加过这两次聚会之一，非常感谢你的光临，即使当时并没有太多关于它的事先信息。你们真的是试验对象。但这意味这明年，我们将举办10次这样的聚会，不仅在澳大利亚，还将在世界各地。我们将从堪培拉开始。我们还将在悉尼再办一场，
another one in Melbourne. We're going to do one in Queensland. And then we're heading over to the UK and to Europe and also to the US. Hopefully we can bring it to more places later on in the year, but we're going slow. We're taking baby steps with this. But I'm just so excited for that. And I'm so excited for what 2025 is going to bring. So with all of my overwhelming gratitude, decide, I want to introduce you to our theme for 2025. So long-term listeners of the podcast will know that each year I'd like to choose a theme, a theme for the year, a theme and attitude basically for what we're going to bring into 2025. So 2024, it was our year for taking risks. And 2025, it is our year for fully trusting ourselves.
墨尔本再办一场。我们将在昆士兰办一场。然后我们要前往英国、欧洲以及美国。希望在今年晚些时候能把它带到更多地方，但我们要稳步推进。我们在这方面迈出婴儿步。但我对此感到非常兴奋。我也对2025年将带来的一切感到非常兴奋。因此，抛开我所有压倒性的感激之情，我想向大家介绍我们2025年的主题。因此，播客的长期听众会知道，每年我都喜欢选择一个主题，一个年度主题，一个态度，基本上是我们带入2025年的态度。所以2024年，是我们承担风险的一年。而2025年，是我们完全信任自己的一年。
Now, the opposite of anxiety is trust. And so what this theme really means for me this year is allowing ourselves to be scared, allowing ourselves to be uncomfortable, allowing ourselves to feel anxiety about the future, about our circumstances, and trusting ourselves anyway, almost being delusional in how much we trust ourselves and our path. that is an amazing power to have and we're going to talk about it more in just a second but to explain
现在，焦虑的反面就是信任。所以这个主题今年对我们来说真正的意义在于，允许自己感到害怕，允许自己感到不舒服，允许自己对未来、对我们的处境感到焦虑，无论如何都要信任自己，甚至在信任自己和我们的道路时达到一种近乎妄想的程度。这是一种令人惊叹的力量，我们稍后会详细讨论，但为了解释
the reason firstly as to why I like to choose a theme instead of a goal or a new year's resolution it's because a theme to me applies to everything so it's a mindset it's an attitude it's an approach it's a lens through which you can see your whole life not just one goal at a time so instead of having to set you know a goal for every area of my life a professional goal, a relationship goal, a financial goal, a personal goal, a health goal, whatever it is. Instead, you prioritize one larger idea that influences all of these elements at once. And by doing so, you don't have to be a stretch thin trying to accomplish five to ten individual things. You know, all of your attention is going to be focused on aligning your behavior with the theme of trusting yourself,
原因首先，为什么我喜欢选择一个主题而不是一个目标或新年决心，是因为在我看来，主题适用于所有事物——它是一种心态，一种态度，一种方法，是一种看待你整个人生的视角，而不是一次只关注一个目标。因此，不必为我生活的每一个领域设定目标——职业目标、关系目标、财务目标、个人目标、健康目标，无论是什么。相反，你优先考虑一个更大的理念，同时影响所有这些元素。通过这样做，你就不必为了试图完成五到十个单独的事情而分身乏术。你知道，你所有的注意力都将集中在使你的行为与信任自己的主题保持一致，
going after what you want, deciding what is and what isn't for you, and knowing that you can pursue that even when it scares you. I think that's a really, really powerful mindset to have. And this idea works much better for me, this perspective, this method, especially since our brains have such finite cognitive resources and we really struggle with attention and sometimes with motivation. So instead, when I say I am someone who trusts myself or I say I'm someone who takes risks or whatever your theme is for the year, it stretches a lot wider. It reaches new areas and I really do find that the transformation in my life is deeper. So, yes, that is my basic premise or explanation for this way of going about things and why
追求你想要的，决定什么是或不是为你而设的，并且知道即使在你感到害怕时，你也可以追求它。我认为这是一种非常非常强大的心态。这种想法对我来说效果更好，这种观点、这种方法，特别是考虑到我们的大脑拥有如此有限的认知资源，我们在注意力有时甚至在动力上都感到很吃力。因此，相反，当我宣称我是一个相信自己的人，或者我宣称我是一个敢于冒险的人，无论你当年的主题是什么，它的范围要广泛得多。它触及新的领域，我确实发现我生活中的转变更加深刻。所以，是的，这就是我处理事情的方式的基本前提或解释，以及为什么
this is how I approach the new year. I think obviously this is also a time when we can really gather. harmonize ourselves around something new and a fresh purposeful philosophy on life because of the emotional and mental significance of new beginnings, especially for our brains. And there is this theory in psychology called the fresh start effect, which basically explains how when you think about it rather arbitrary landmarks like a new year or a birthday or a new job, a new season, it really motivates us to break away from past habits because it gives the impression of a blank slate. And yes, the new year is really just a one day, you know, it's just a day and another day and another day.
这就是我对待新年的方式。我认为显然这也是我们真正可以聚集的时候。由于新开始在情感和心理上的重要性，特别对我们的大脑而言，我们可以围绕一些新事物以及关于生活的新鲜且有目的的哲学来协调我们自己。心理学上有一个理论叫做“全新开始效应”，它基本上解释了当你想到诸如新年、生日、新工作、新季节这样有些随意的地标时，它确实能激励我们摆脱过去的习惯，因为它给人一种空白石板的印象。是的，新年其实只是一天，你知道，它只是一天又一天，又一天。
It's just we have put these, you know, human, human ideas around time passing. But that is significant enough. And a 2015 study that really examined this and examined this across five laboratory experiments and it found consistently that when humans are given this idea of a new beginning or a new time period, it really increases our intentions to pursue our goals and ultimately our success in achieving them. So this is your time. This is when to start. This is when to take up a new theme. So without further ado, let's talk about why this year is going to be your year for fully trusting yourself. Firstly, let's start off by really examining what self-trusts.
这只是我们围绕时间的流逝所赋予的那些人类的、人类的概念。但这已经足够重要了。2015年的一项研究对此进行了真正的检验，跨越了五个实验室实验进行考察，结果始终一致：当人类被赋予新开始或新时期的概念时，它确实会增强我们追求目标的意愿，并最终增加我们实现这些目标的成功率。所以这是你的时间。这是开始的时候。这是采纳新主题的时候。因此，废话少说，让我们来谈谈为什么今年将是你完全信任自己的一年。首先，让我们从真正审视什么是自我信任开始。
looks like. Self-trust is, firstly, not having all the answers. Self-trust is not arrogance or ego. It is instead a deep belief in your ability to encounter problems and get through them. But also an equally deep belief that you know what your life should look like. You know what you want from your life. And you are so sure of it that you are willing to go after it, despite what other people might believe, despite the naysayers. Essentially, self-trust to me is the opposite of self-doubt. You know, where self-doubt might call you a fraud and might say, you're not capable of this, you're not ready. You can't possibly handle this. Self-trust is something even greater than confidence. It's steadiness. It's self-assurance. You can look at a challenge, say, for example, an uncertain
样貌。首先，自我信任并非拥有所有答案。自我信任绝非傲慢或自负。相反，它是对你能够面对问题并克服困难的能力的深切信念。同时，这也包含着同样坚定的信念：你清楚自己的人生应该是什么样子。你知道你从生活中追求什么。你对此如此笃信，以至于你愿意不顾其他人的看法，不顾那些唱反调的人，勇往直前。本质上，对我而言，自我信任就是自我怀疑的反面。你知道，如果说自我怀疑可能会给你贴上骗子的标签，可能会说你没有这个能力，你还没准备好。你绝对无法应付这个。自我信任甚至比自信还要宏大。它是一种坚定。它是一种自信。你可以面对一个挑战，比如，例如，一个不确定的
future, which a lot of us in our 20s are dealing with, or a new job or, or, or, or a big move, and you can confidently say, I actually don't know how this is going to work out, but I trust the future version of myself to do what's best and to handle it. Therefore, that allows you to take the leap. I think there's this incredible article by psychology today that explains the roots of self-trust, and they just put it so well. And what they basically explain is that when we look at examples of people who are self-trusting, We find that they have clarity and confidence in their choices.
未来，我们20多岁的人中有很多人正在面对这种情况，或者是一份新工作、或者、或者、或者是一次大的搬迁，你可以自信地说：“实际上我不知道这会如何发展，但我相信未来的自己会做最适合的事情并妥善处理。”因此，这能让你勇敢跃进。我认为《今日心理学》上有一篇不可思议的文章，解释了自我信任的根源，他们表达得太棒了。他们基本上解释说，当我们寻找那些自我信任的人的例子时，
They are healthily dependent on other people whilst also independent. So they're not overly dependent on other people, but they're also not hyper-independent. They speak with authority that comes from a very deep place but is not arrogant. They are good observers. And they have also, and this is critical, cultivated the ability to learn from their experiences, both the successes and failures. And I think we can acknowledge why that's so important. When we don't have self-trust,
我们发现他们对自己的选择有清晰的认识和信心。他们对他人保持健康的依赖，同时也保持独立。因此，他们不过度依赖他人，但也不是极度独立。他们说话充满权威感，这种权威发自内心深处却不傲慢。他们是出色的观察者。并且他们还培养了（这一点至关重要）从经验中学习的能力，无论是成功还是失败。我想我们都能认识到为什么这一点如此重要。当我们缺乏自我信任时，
we feel very much pulled by other people's opinions and judgments, or we feel very much dictated by failure, or we rely too heavily on external validation. So what that means is that what someone else thinks about me or thinks it's right for me must be the truth, because my internal validation system is damage. or it's left me. So I see this a lot, actually, especially amongst those of us in our 20s, because given our age, I do feel like we sometimes believe that we don't have full authority over our
我们会深深受到他人意见和判断的左右，或者被失败所左右，或者过度依赖外部验证。这意味着，别人对我的看法或认为什么对我才是正确的，必定就是真相，因为我的内部验证系统已经受损。或者它已经抛弃了我。所以我经常看到这种情况，尤其是在我们20多岁的人中间，因为考虑到我们的年龄，我确实觉得我们有时会认为我们对自己的生活没有完全的掌控权，
lives because we're so young and we're just getting started and also we're so confused. So we're looking for someone to say, actually, no, you're wrong. Let me show you how to do it. And we're like, thank God. Thank gosh. Someone's going to tell me what to do. And one way this manifests is when you have to make a really important decision. and you may ask every single person in your life what they think. What do you think? Should I do this? Should I not do this?
因为我们太年轻，才刚刚开始，而且我们也非常困惑。所以我们在寻找某个人说：“实际上，不对，你错了。让我来告诉你怎么做。”我们就会说：“谢天谢地。谢天谢地。有人要告诉我该怎么做。”这种情况的一种表现是，当你必须做出一个非常重要的决定时，
Should I go? Should I stay? Please give me the answers. And yet, you are still confused. Or you still feel like, despite all this additional information that's coming from people's opinions, you still can't act because at the end of the day, a decision is yours to make. Even if other people are saying, you have to do this, you should do this, this is what I think is. best for you. You are still the one who makes the decision and you are still the one that will have to
你可能会问生活中的每一个人他们的看法。你觉得呢？我该这样做吗？我不该这样做吗？我应该走吗？我应该留吗？请给我答案。然而，你依然感到困惑。或者你仍然觉得，尽管有来自别人意见的这些额外信息，你依然无法行动，因为归根结底，决定权在你手中。即使别人说，你必须这么做，你应该这么做，这就是我认为对你最好的。你依然是做出决定的人，你依然是那个必须
carry the burden, the potential burden of that being the wrong decision. So it's not the decision that you fear. You fear change and you fear not being able to handle any unexpected consequences of your choices. I also see it when we don't want to step out of our comfort zone because we are scared of not being able to manage it alone. I honestly believe. that a lack of self-trust is why so many of us stay in relationships, and that includes friendships that aren't fulfilling because we don't think that we can trust ourselves to be happy alone. Think about, you know, relationships in your life currently. Why, you know that the relationship isn't actually fulfilling. It's not a fun relationship. It drains your energy. You feel like
承担负担、承担这可能是错误决定带来的潜在负担的人。所以你害怕的不是决定。你害怕的是改变，你害怕无法应对你的选择所带来的任何意想不到的后果。我也看到这种情况发生在当我们不想迈出舒适区时，因为我们害怕无法独自应付。我真心相信，缺乏自我信任正是我们许多人留在一段关系中的原因，这其中包括那些无法令人满意的友谊，因为我们认为自己无法相信自己能够独自快乐。想想你生活中目前的关系。为什么，你知道这段关系实际上并不能带来满足感。这不是一段有趣的感情。它耗尽了你的精力。你觉得
you let out a huge sigh of relief every time the hangout ends or you feel anxious every time you see them but we hold on to those relationships because we don't trust ourselves to be alone we don't trust ourselves to handle the emotions of having to let the relationship go it all comes down to this sense of self-doubt who am i without other people dictating my character a lack of self-trust is also why we don't take risks, like pursuing our passion, even if it's, you know, a side project or solo traveling, because we don't feel like we can trust ourselves to figure things out that we don't yet know and be adaptable. So when it comes down to it, we can see that this actually filters into every element of our lives. And it might be why it might be at the root, actually, of a lot of
每次聚会结束时你都会长出一口气，或者每次见到他们你都会感到焦虑，但我们仍然维系着这些关系，因为我们不相信自己能独自一人，我们不相信自己能够应付不得不放手这段关系的那些情绪。这一切都归结于这种自我怀疑的感觉：如果没有别人来定义我的性格，我是谁？缺乏自我信任也是为什么我们不愿冒险，比如追求我们的激情（哪怕它只是一个副业项目）或独自旅行的原因，因为我们觉得我们无法信任自己去搞清楚那些我们还不知道的事情并做到随机应变。所以归根结底，我们可以看到这实际上渗透到了我们生活的方方面面。这可能就是根源所在，实际上是我们许多
our indecisiveness, our stagnation, our fear. Think about just for a second, how many situations come up for us nearly every day in our 20s and beyond really that require a baseline of self-trust to accomplish. And I'm going to give you a little list here. Choosing a major at university or college or a career. Asking for a promotion, setting boundaries, standing up for yourself, making big purchases or saving or investing, trusting that you know what's best for your body and your health, making risky decisions, even deciding what's worth your energy. That all, all of those decisions require you to be able to look in the mirror and say, hey, you might not know all the answers, but I trust that you're going to figure it out. So do what feels best. I trust you. FOMO is another
优柔寡断、停滞不前、恐惧的根源。试想一下，在我们的20多岁甚至更远的岁月中，几乎每天都会出现多少需要基本的自我信任才能完成的情况。我将为你列出一张小清单。在大学里选择专业或职业。争取晋升，设定界限，为自己挺身而出，进行大额购买、储蓄或投资，相信自己最了解自己的身体和健康，做出冒险的决定，甚至决定什么才值得你付出精力。所有这些决定，所有这些决定都要求你能够看着镜子里的人说：“嘿，你可能不知道所有答案，但我相信你会弄明白的。所以，去做感觉最对的事吧。我信任你。”“错失恐惧症”（FOMO）是另一个
one actually that just came to the top of my mind just then. FOMO comes into this big time. If you have self-trust, you may be more easily convinced that you have to be where everyone else is, doing what they are, even when that might not suit you because you don't feel confident or safe in your own choices or your own company. So we say self-trust and we think it's a small thing, but it really does touch our lives in a much deeper way. And there's actually a theory in psychology called trust theory, which says that trusting ourselves is what allows us to trust others, our friends, our family, our colleagues, and that is a prerequisite for so many other things. Trust, I don't know, I really don't know why it doesn't get more attention. It's so
刚刚浮现在我脑海中的情况。FOMO在这里扮演了重要角色。如果你有自我信任，你可能就不会那么轻易地被说服，认为你必须去所有其他人都在的地方，做他们正在做的事，即使这可能并不适合你，因为你在自己的选择或自己的陪伴中并不感到自信或安全。所以我们嘴上说着自我信任，觉得这是一件小事，但它确实以更深的方式触及了我们的生活。心理学上其实有一个理论叫做“信任理论”，该理论指出，信任自己正是我们能够信任他人（我们的朋友、家人、同事）的前提，而这是许多其他事物的前提条件。信任，我不知道，我真的不知道为什么它没有得到更多的关注。作为一个运作良好的现代人，它是如此
important to be a well-functioning human. And a really great study that talks about this was published in 2012 from Huntington University in the US. And it talks about the correlation between self-esteem, loneliness and self-trust. And they found that when you are low on self-trust, you also experience loneliness more intensely. Your self-esteem is lower and you feel more anxious about your relationships. This was totally me. Maybe like six or seven years back, I was in the pit of this. I had absolutely no trust in myself.
重要。美国亨廷顿大学在2012年发表了一项非常棒的研究，探讨了这一点。它探讨了自尊、孤独感和自我信任之间的相关性。他们发现，当你的自我信任度较低时，你体验到的孤独感也会更加强烈。你的自尊心更低，对人际关系的焦虑感也更强。这完全就是当年的我。大概六七年前，我正身处这种状态的泥潭中。我对自我完全没有信任。
I was so doubtful of every single thing I did. and I kind of approached relationships, friendships in particular, kind of like a little injured bird being like, please like me. And if you don't like me, don't worry, I'll change for you. Like, I have no strong self-concept because I don't know who I am and I don't trust myself to figure it out. So I was very like bendable and easily manipulated by friendships because I really did not believe that I knew what was best for me and I did not believe that I could feel like I've
我对自己的每一个举动都充满怀疑。我对待人际关系（尤其是友谊）的方式，有点像一只受伤的小鸟，心里想着：“求求你喜欢我吧。如果你不喜欢我，别担心，我会为你改变的。”就像这样，我没有强烈的自我概念，因为我不知道我是谁，我也不相信自己能搞清楚这一点。所以我非常容易妥协，很容易被友情操纵，因为我真的不相信自己知道什么对我最好，我也不相信如果没有别人告诉我我很好，我就会觉得自己很好。这就是我的一小段个人故事。然而，你知道，如果我们今年的主题是扭转我们对自我信任的缺乏，我们首先需要真正了解究竟是什么首先损害了它，然后如何真正撤销这些互动，那些导致你产生大量自我怀疑的情感互动、情感创伤。因此，我将稍作暂停，当我们回来时，我想讨论我们缺乏自我信任的根源，以及在这个简短的休息之后如何重建它。
was okay without someone else telling me that I was okay. So there's a little personal story for you. However, you know, if our theme this year is to reverse our lack of self-trust, we probably, you know, you firstly really need to know what damages it in the first place and then how to really, you know, undo those interactions, those emotional interactions, the emotional trauma that has caused you to really have a lot of self-doubt. So I'm going to take a quick pause, and then when we return, I want to talk about the roots of our lack of self-trust and how to rebuild it after this short break.
（广告部分）
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些在健康行业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症吗？我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是“2%”，可以在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得当年戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上猛拍小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“回顾过去”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·恩格里斯。
episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的“快克”（快克可卡因）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。欢迎收听我的新播客“艰难求知”，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Ryan, hard. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth,
我说的是特里普·方丹，瑞安，瑞安，真难。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，而我们仍在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们会看记分牌。生活变得关乎输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现作为一个好人很重要当你来到人间时，还是你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。和我，科尔·盖姆斯一起，在我的新播客“艰难求知”中进行关于治愈、成长、
fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free IHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“艰难求知”并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处亲子丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士。我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·亚莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So the theory with self-trust goes that we are all born with an internal compass. And this internal emotional compass is really what allows us. to direct our life by following our north. And our north is something that really develops as children and then into our teenage years
劳拉·欧文斯终于自食其果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。所以关于自我信任的理论是，我们生来都带有内部指南针。这个内在的情感指南针其实就是让我们能够通过跟随北方来指引我们的人生。而我们的北方是在我们作为儿童以及后来进入青少年时期真正发展起来的东西，
and it's basically our purpose, what we want from life, our values, our truth. Along the way, though, the compass is really thrown off by things like excessive criticism from family, from friends, from people in general, overbearing parental pressure as well, especially, you know, when our parents don't allow us to be individuals and they keep us emotionally and physically dependent on them by making all our choices for us or shaming us for doing something counter to what they want. Self-trust is also damaged by internal patterns like people-pleasing, a fear of failure, perfectionism,
基本上是我们的目标、我们对生活的诉求、我们的价值观、我们的真理。然而，一路走来，这个指南针被诸如家庭、朋友、一般人的过度批评、以及专横的父母压力（尤其是当我们的父母不允许我们成为独立个体，而是通过为我们做出所有选择或因为我们做了违背他们意愿的事而羞辱我们，从而让我们在情感和物理上都依赖他们）等因素彻底打乱了。自我信任也会被诸如讨好型人格、对失败的恐惧、完美主义等内部模式所破坏，
essentially meaning that we don't really feel like we can meet our own standards or that letting ourselves be in control of our lives could mean that we would make major mistakes. I also want to talk about the influence of past relationship betrayal and, you know, separately ignoring our intuition and how those two sometimes come together. So past relationship trauma and betrayal can significantly harm our sense of self-trust because these experiences often disrupt our ability to accurately interpret and rely on our judgments and instincts.
本质上意味着我们真的觉得无法达到自己的标准，或者让自己掌控生活可能意味着我们会犯下大错。我还想谈谈过去的人际关系背叛的影响，以及（分开来看）忽视我们的直觉，以及这两者有时如何结合在一起。因此，过去的关系创伤和背叛会显著损害我们的自我信任感，因为这些经历经常破坏我们准确解读并依赖我们的判断和直觉的能力。
You know, gaslighting is a big component of this, but when someone we trusted, deceives or hurts us. It creates a real deep sense of confusion and self-blame. And it leads us to really question our ability to discern red flags, to make safe choices, to protect ourselves emotionally. Big caveat here. None of this is actually our fault. Literally not a single part.
你知道，煤气灯操纵（心理控制）是其中的一个重要组成部分，但当我们信任的人欺骗或伤害我们时，会产生一种深刻的困惑感和自我责备感。这导致我们真正质疑自己识别危险信号、做出安全选择以及在情感上保护自己的能力。这里有一个重要警告。这一切其实都不是我们的错。字面意思，连一点都不是。
But this external erosion of trust in others makes us believe that it is. It makes us very hypervigilant. It makes us doubtful of our own. perceptions. You know, it's honestly, one of the craziest things to me in my mind is that love is such a beautiful thing that when it is used cruelly and when it is turned sour, how much it can hurt someone. And that is really what betrayal does. And it doesn't just hurt our heart. It hurts our entire perception of self. And that betrayal often triggers feelings of shame, worthlessness, inadequacy. And that further distances us from the confidence we
但这种对他人信任的外部侵蚀让我们以为是我们的错。这让我们变得非常高度警惕。这让我们对自己感知产生怀疑。你知道，老实说，我脑海中最疯狂的事情之一就是爱是如此美丽的事物，当它被残酷地使用并且变质时，它能对一个人造成多大的伤害。这就是背叛所做的事情。它不仅伤害我们的心脏。它伤害了我们的整个自我认知。这种背叛通常会引发羞耻感、无价值感、不安全感。这进一步使我们远离信任我们自己的决定所需的
need to trust our own decisions. Over time as well, repeated relational trauma can really embed within us a belief that we are incapable of navigating relationships effectively and that perpetuates a cycle of self-doubt and a fear of vulnerability as well. So if you're really struggling to trust yourself, sometimes the origin of that is really in a past relationship where, of course, you were made to feel like, you know, of course I can't trust myself. Because look at how this turned out. this person has just treated me so poorly that I have no sense of self anymore. It's a really big contributor. Ignoring our intuition is another component of this.
自信。随着时间的推移，反复的关系创伤真的会在我们内心根深蒂固一种信念，即我们无力有效地应对人际关系，这会延续一种自我怀疑的循环以及对脆弱的恐惧。因此，如果你真的在努力信任自己，有时其根源实际上在于一段过去的关系中，在那里，你当然会被弄得觉得自己无法信任自己。因为看看结果如何。这个人对我的态度如此糟糕，以至于我不再有任何自我意识。这是一个非常重要的促成因素。忽视我们的直觉是这其中的另一个组成部分。
And that's not necessarily ignoring our intuition in a relationship, but in everyday situations. That also erode self-trust. I read this really beautiful quote, intuition is our birthright as humans. It comes with our DNA. It comes with our blueprint. And a 2016 study really showed that. And it showed that when you and I have gut instincts about something, it's actually because our brains are processing a lot more information subconsciously
这不一定是在一段关系中忽视直觉，而是在日常生活中。这也是侵蚀自我信任的因素。我读到过一句非常美的名言：直觉是我们作为人类的与生俱来的权利。它随我们的DNA一同到来。它随我们的蓝图一同到来。2016年的一项研究真正展示了这一点。它表明，当你我对某事有直觉时，实际上是因为我们的大脑在潜意识中处理的信息比我们意识中能想到的要多得多。
than we can think about consciously. So when, for example, you have a gut feeling, you know, you meet someone, you're like, I don't think you're a nice person. I think you're a bad egg. Or you're in this situation and you get that sudden feeling of like, I shouldn't be here. I shouldn't be here. something about this is wrong, I need to go.
因此，举个例子，当你有一种直觉时，你知道的，你遇到了某个人，你心里想：“我觉得你不是个好人。我觉得你是个坏蛋。”或者你身处这种境地，你突然有一种感觉：“我不应该在这里。我不应该在这里。这地方有些不对劲，我得走了。”
That is something that oftentimes you really should trust. However, when you continuously ignore that intuition, you tell your brain that what it's doing isn't useful and how you perceive the world is wrong. Anxiety also comes into play here. Obviously, anxiety is the opposite of trust. And so anxiety really messes with our intuition. It says, wait, you should be scared right now. you should be scared right now.
这往往是你真的应该信任的东西。然而，当你不断忽视这种直觉时，你就在告诉你的大脑，它所做的事情是没有用的，你对世界的看法是错误的。焦虑在这里也发挥了作用。显然，焦虑是信任的反面。因此，焦虑把我们的直觉搞得一团糟。它说：“等等，你现在应该害怕。你现在应该害怕。”
And the more rational part of your brain is like, there's nothing to be scared of. I trust myself. Like this is so fine. But your brain's like, no, no, no, be anxious, be anxious. It's messing with your intuition. Anxiety, opposite of self-trust. Intuition, a huge, important part of self-trust. So over time, this can lead to self-doubt, second-guessing, and an inability to really
而你大脑中更理性的部分则认为：“没有什么好怕的。我相信自己。这好得很。”但你的大脑却说：“不，不，不，要焦虑，要焦虑。”它在搞乱你的直觉。焦虑，是自我信任的反面。直觉，是自我信任的一个巨大且重要的部分。因此，随着时间的推移，这会导致自我怀疑、事后诸葛亮般的猜疑，以及真正无法
confidently make decisions. So psychologically, this disconnection, fosters a lot of confusion and we become less attuned to our instincts but also our needs so repeatedly silencing our intuition it can also diminish our self-efficacy and that is our belief in our ability to handle challenges or to you know create the outcome that we want and that's really critical for personal growth and resilience you need self-efficacy if you want to do anything if you want to you know, run a marathon, you want to finish a really huge personal project, anything, any change in your lifestyle, you actually have to believe that you are able to do something and able to
自信地做出决定。所以在心理上，这种脱节助长了大量的混乱，我们对自己的直觉以及需求变得不那么敏感——因此，反复压制我们的直觉也会削弱我们的自我效能感，而这就是我们对处理挑战或创造我们想要的结果的能力的信念。这对个人成长和韧性至关重要。如果你想做任何事情，如果你想（你知道的）跑马拉松，你想完成一个巨大的个人项目，任何事，生活方式的任何改变，你都需要自我效能感，你实际上必须相信自己能够做成某事，并且能够
achieve what you set your mind to. But if you lack self-trust, of course you're not going to be able to believe that. And if your intuition is off, if you keep ignoring the signs that you should be doing something, that this is your calling or that you can do it, or ignoring your intuition saying, go this way, go that way, all of this is really, really connected. I hope that's been persuasive for you, but, and I hope you understand that relationship better now. If you are struggling with self-trust, I really think that it's probably something that has been diminished slowly over time until you are at a point now where instinct, intuition, confidence, self-efficacy, they have all been replaced with doubt.
实现你下定决心要做的事。但如果你缺乏自我信任，你当然无法相信这一点。如果你的直觉出现偏差，如果你一直忽视那些你应该做某事的信号，即这是你的召唤或者你能做到，或者忽视你的直觉说“往这边走，往那边走”，所有这一切都是真正、真正紧密相连的。我希望这能说服你，而且我希望你现在能更好地理解这种关系。如果你正在与自我信任作斗争，我真的认为这可能是随着时间推移被慢慢消磨的东西，直到你现在达到了这样一个点：直觉、自信、自我效能感，全都被怀疑所取代。
So that being said, going into 2025, how can we reverse some of these processes and really reclaim our intuition and our self-assurance? If this is the year for trusting yourself, I think that firstly you really are going to have to prove it to yourself, prove that you can. And that's going to require some experimentation, some trial and error and pushing yourself into a place of discomfort, not into a place of danger, but into a place where you can truly grow. I really believe this. Self-trust is actually a skill. It's a muscle that can be built with practice and commitment to almost a routine. And the routine I'm talking about is an emotional routine. It's a psychological routine. It involves taking chances that feel big and important and showing yourself that the outcome that you want is what will come from this. So how do I want you to practice proving to yourself that you can trust yourself, I want you to start saying yes to
话虽如此，迈入2025年，我们该如何扭转其中一些过程，真正重新找回我们的直觉和自信呢？如果今年是信任自己的一年，我认为首先你真的必须向自己证明这一点，证明你能做到。这需要进行一些实验、一些试错，并把自己推向一个感到不舒服的地方，不是走向危险的地方，而是走向一个你能真正成长的地方。我真的相信这一点。自信其实是一种技能。它是一块通过练习和对几乎一整套常规的承诺就能建立起来的肌肉。而我所说的常规，是一种情感上的常规。它是一种心理常规。它包括承担那些感觉重大而重要的风险，向自己证明你想要的结果将会由此产生。所以，我希望你如何练习向自己证明你可以信任自己呢？我希望你开始对
things that you might not quite feel ready to do instead of waiting for the perfect time. Because the perfect time is a fallacy. It never actually comes. And what I still want you to see is, you know, win or fail, win or lose, success or failure, whatever it is. You are still going to be okay. You will still survive every single time, even if things aren't perfect. So let me give you some examples of how we can practice this in 2025, how we can make self-trust part of our routine. So a big one, and every single one of us can do this, is to go to things alone, even if you're scared or even if it could be a disaster.
那些你可能觉得还没完全准备好去做的事情说“我愿意”，而不是等待完美的时机。因为完美的时机是一个谬论。它其实永远不会到来。而且我仍然希望你明白，你知道的，无论是赢是输，成功还是失败，不管是什么。你依然会没事的。每一次你都能挺过去，即使事情并不完美。所以让我给你举几个例子，看看我们如何在2025年实践这一点，如何将自信融入我们的常规之中。其中很重要的一点，我们每个人都能做到，那就是独自去参加各种活动，哪怕你感到害怕，哪怕这可能会是一场灾难。
So you get invited to a party, go by yourself. You really want to go to an event, you don't know anyone, go by yourself. There's a movie that no one else wants to see with you. Go by yourself. Go out for dinner by yourself. there's a lot of fear around that sometimes, especially if you're someone who is quite socially anxious like myself. It's a lot of fear.
所以你受邀去参加派对，一个人去。你真的很想去参加一个活动，但谁也不认识，一个人去。有一部电影别人都不想陪你看，一个人去。一个人去外面吃晚餐。有时候这会带来很大的恐惧，尤其是如果你像我一样是一个有些社交焦虑的人。有很大的恐惧。
Am I going to be able to handle this? What if someone looks at me the wrong way? What if someone judges me? Doesn't matter. You trust yourself. This is your year for trusting yourself. And someone who trusts themselves would be okay with going into that situation,
我能应付得了吗？如果有人用异样的眼光看我怎么办？如果有人评判我怎么办？没关系。你要相信自己。今年是你信任自己的一年。而一个信任自己的人，会坦然接受进入那种状况，
not knowing what other people are thinking, not knowing how it's going to work out, knowing that they're still going to have fun and get where they want out of it, out of it by being alone. Another way that you can really make self-trust part of your routine is to confront a big fear that you have this year. It could be of public speaking, of traveling alone, going on a blind date, of flying,
不知道别人在想什么，不知道事情会如何发展，但知道通过独自一人，他们依然能获得乐趣并得到他们想要的东西。你能真正让自信成为日常常规的另一种方法，就是去面对你今年面临的一个巨大恐惧。这可能是关于公开演讲、独自旅行、去相亲、坐飞机、
of being embarrassed, of going to the gym. What is the fear that you have in your mind right now? Just think about it really quickly. That is holding you back. So you really don't know how you react and how bad. brave and strong you can be until you face a fear and you see how your reaction will surprise you. The anxiety that we feel in regards to a big fear is normally actually anticipation. And then when you get there, when you get into the moment of your fear, yes, it might be
害怕出丑、害怕去健身房。你脑海中现在的恐惧是什么？快速想一想。它正在阻碍你前进。所以，在你直面恐惧并看到你的反应如何让你大吃一惊之前，你真的不知道自己会做出什么反应，会有多勇敢、多坚强。我们对巨大恐惧感到的焦虑，通常其实是期待。然后当你到达那里，当你进入恐惧的时刻，是的，它可能是
uncomfortable. Yes, it might not go your way. But actually, a lot of our anxiety tends to fade. the adrenaline takes over and you get to see yourself adapt. You get to see yourself in all of your glory, face a fear, and come out of it. And what that really requires is also leaving room for the mess of trusting yourself. Now this is a really important component. And I have to thank an article from Well and Good for This. And they interviewed a really amazing author called Liz Moody, who wrote the book, A Hundred Ways to Change Your Life.
不舒服的。是的，事情可能不会如你所愿。但实际上，我们的许多焦虑往往会消退，肾上腺素占据上风，你会看到自己适应环境。你会看到自己在所有的光芒中面对恐惧并克服它。而这真正需要的，也是为信任自己的混乱留出空间。现在这是一个非常重要的组成部分。我必须为此感谢Well and Good的一篇文章。他们采访了一位非常了不起的作家，名叫Liz Moody，她写了一本名为《改变人生的100种方法》的书。
Really good book also. amazing. It's on like one of my, probably one of my top 10 books. And she made this incredible point about self-trust. She said, doing what you think is right for you isn't always going to be a clean process. In learning to trust yourself, you will make painful mistakes. You will have to give up on things. You will have to let things go. But as you learn, disappointing people, closing certain chapters of your life, making mistakes, you realize that those are all important parts of trust in yourself. And sometimes that might feel like a really big loss to bear, right?
也是一本非常好的书。太棒了。它大概排在我的前十本好书里。她就自信发表了一个不可思议的观点。她说，做你认为对的事情并不总是一个清晰的过程。在学会信任自己的过程中，你会犯下痛苦的错误。你将不得不放弃一些东西。你将不得不放手一些事情。但当你学会让人们失望、关闭人生的某些篇章、犯下错误时，你会意识到这些都是信任自己的重要部分。有时这可能感觉是一个很难承受的巨大损失，对吧？
Sometimes you might be like, ah, I really don't have it in me right now to experience failure or to lose a friendship or to stand up for myself. That's a totally normal reaction. But you will never build self-trust if you don't just try step by step, maybe steps at a time to encounter situations where you don't know how things are going to go where there is fear there and choose trust over doubt. the more risks you take in service of trusting yourself, the more reinforcement you'll get as well, and the more that you'll realize that this is an exercise that is worthwhile.
有时你可能会想，啊，我现在真的没有勇气去经历失败，或者失去一段友谊，或者为自己挺身而出。这完全是一种正常的反应。但如果你不尝试一步一步地、也许是一步一个脚印地去面对那些你不知道事情会如何发展、充满恐惧的状况，并选择信任而非怀疑，你就永远无法建立自信。你为信任自己而冒的风险越多，你得到的强化就会越多，你也会越发意识到这是一项值得进行的锻炼。
So even when the decisions don't always work out, it's still actually a really valuable exercise. It's basically building an internal sense of like okayness. Like this is going to be fine. And this really brings me to my next point, which is intuition, which is to really examine when your intuition is gut instinct and when it is anxiety. When is it actually not intuition, but it's just fear? So I think that a really great way to think about intuition is that intuition isn't just something that is in us to avoid things. It's not just an avoidance technique.
所以，即使这些决定并不总是奏效，它其实仍然是一项非常宝贵的锻炼。这基本上是在建立一种内在的“一切都会好起来”的感觉。就像这一切都会没事的。这真的让我想到了我的下一个观点，也就是直觉，那就是真正去检验什么时候你的直觉是纯粹的本能，什么时候它是焦虑。什么时候它其实不是直觉，而只是恐惧？所以我觉得思考直觉的一个绝佳方式是，直觉不仅仅是我们用来逃避事情的东西。它不仅仅是一种逃避技巧。
Intuition is also something that guides us to abundance. So all of us have this intuition somewhere in us that we should be doing something, that there is something calling us, that there is a purpose that we have, that we should be volunteering more. We should be creating more. We should be writing more. We should be saying yes to more things. Intuition comes in that form as well. It's guiding you to something that's important for who you are. Don't ignore it. Don't listen to the anxious thought that's giving you a reason to doubt your positive intuition. And with your negative intuition, test and see what times is that just anxiety and what times is it actually got instinct? when could I have pushed forward a little bit and really got to the bottom of whether this was my intuition telling me what to do or whether it was just fear? That's a really important challenge.
直觉也是引导我们走向丰盛的东西。所以我们每个人内心深处的某个地方都有这种直觉：我们应该做点什么，有什么在召唤我们，我们有一个人生目标，我们应该做更多的志愿服务。我们应该创作更多。我们应该写更多。我们应该对更多的事情说“好”。直觉也会以这种形式出现。它引导你走向对你的身份至关重要的事情。不要忽视它。不要去听那些给你提供怀疑你积极直觉的理由的焦虑想法。而对于你的消极直觉，去检验并看看在什么时候那只是焦虑，在什么时候它确实是直觉？什么时候我可以稍微推自己一把，真正弄清楚这到底是我的直觉在告诉我该做什么，还是仅仅出于恐惧？这是一个非常重要的挑战。
And I would also challenge you to start reconsidering your need for the approval of others or the validation of your choices. So if you have a positive intuition or a positive gut instinct towards a decision, telling you to do something, telling you to make a big change, to move somewhere, to create something. something to dump someone, whatever it is. I don't think that you need others to tell you that you're right because chances are that if you have that feeling, you already know that this is what you should be doing. And sometimes we bury ourselves again in getting as many of the opinions of others and the advice from others. We do that because we don't want to make a decision. But if you're got instinct to saying, this is something that's really calling me, you've got to do it. Also, these people who give you their advice, right? They're not the ones who have to encounter the decision,
我也想挑战你们，开始重新审视你们对他人认可的需求，或者对你们选择的验证的需求。所以如果你对一个决定有积极的直觉或积极的直觉反应，告诉你去做某事，告诉你做出重大改变，搬到某个地方，创造点什么，甩掉某人，不管是什么。我认为你不需要别人来告诉你你是对的，因为很有可能如果你有这种感觉，你已经知道这就是你应该做的。有时我们再次把自己埋在获取尽可能多他人意见和建议的过程中。我们这样做是因为我们不想做出决定。但如果你的直觉在说，这是真正呼唤我的东西，你必须去做。另外，这些给你建议的人，对吧？他们不是必须面对这个决定的人，
right? They don't actually have to pull the trigger the way that you do. They also probably aren't as invested in this as you are. They probably don't know you as well as you know yourself. They might believe they know what's best for you, but you actually know what's best for you. That's part of self-trust. So what that involves is, yes, making decisions without getting a million pieces of advice from everyone from your best friend to your neighbor to some stranger. They just do what feels best for you, but also just slowly testing that by wearing outfits without, you know, asking if your friends like them, buying the things that you want to buy without asking someone else whether it looks cute. Making career choices without first needing to ask everyone whether it's a good idea. Obviously, we all love feedback, but when you're going after excessive feedback, it can also be a form of avoidance.
对吧？他们其实不用像你那样扣动扳机。他们可能也没有你那么投入。他们可能不如你了解你自己。他们可能认为他们最了解你什么，但你其实最了解你自己。那是自信的一部分。所以这涉及到的就是，是的，在不从每个人那里（从你的最好朋友到你的邻居再到某个陌生人）获取数百万条建议的情况下做出决定，只是去做那些让你感觉最好的事，同时也通过穿衣服来慢慢测试这一点，不，你知道的，不用问你的朋友是否喜欢它们，购买你想买的东西而不问别人它看起来是否可爱。在做职业选择时不需要先去问每个人这是否是个好主意。显然，我们都喜欢反馈，但当你追求过度的反馈时，它也可能是一种逃避的形式。
Avoidance is not self-trust, and that is our year. Our year is for self-trust. So 2025 in summary, your theme is your year for trusting yourself. And what that really means is releasing the need for external validation, tapping into your positive intuition that is telling you this is where you need to be, this is where you need to go, knowing that you can survive being uncomfortable, knowing that you can survive being uncertain, and just seriously living for you. It's a new year, it's a blank page, it's a fresh start. and I know that's rather arbitrary, but sometimes we need the arbitrary idea of a new chapter
逃避不是自信，而今年是我们的年。我们的一年是属于自信的。因此，总结2025年，你的主题就是你信任自己的一年。而这真正意味着释放对外部认可的需求，倾听告诉你“这就是你需要呆的地方、这就是你需要去的地方”的积极直觉，知道你能挺过不适，知道你能挺过不确定，并且真正为自己而活。新的一年，一张白纸，一个新的开始，我知道这有点随心所欲，但有时我们需要新篇章的这种随心所欲的想法，
to really commit to a new mindset and a new lifestyle. And I hope that this is one that really resonates with you. If your year for fully trusting yourself is not the theme that suits you, I really also implore you to come up with your own. It could be your year for self-discipline. It could be your year for taking risks if that wasn't the one that you took on last year. It could be your year for gratitude. It could be your year for saying yes.
来真正致力于一种新的心态和新的生活方式。我希望这是一个真正能引起你共鸣的概念。如果“完全信任自己的一年”不是适合你的主题，我也真的恳请你想出你自己的主题。它可以是你的一年，用于自我纪律。如果去年你没有采取行动，今年可以是你承担风险的一年。它可以是你充满感激的一年。它可以是你对生活说“好”的一年。
it could be your year for eliminating people pleasing what is your theme and how does it touch every area of your life write it on a piece of paper write it real big have it on your desk have it in your car have it at your you know place of work anywhere on your mirror so that you can fully embrace how a theme will touch every single part of your year thank you so much for listening and thank you so much for your support in 2024 or 2025 is about to be a wild year. I can't wait to meet more of you, speak to you, hear your journeys. I just, that's like my favorite part about this. You guys just inspire me so much.
它可以是你消除取悦他人的一年。你的主题是什么，它如何触及你生活的方方面面？把它写在一张纸上，写得很大，放在你的桌子上，放在你的车里，放在你的工作地方，或者镜子上的任何地方，这样你就可以完全拥抱一个主题将如何触及你一年中的每一个部分。非常感谢大家的收听，也非常感谢你们在2024年的支持，2025年将是疯狂的一年。我迫不及待地想认识更多的人，与你们交谈，听听你们的旅程。我只是，那就像是我最喜欢的部分。你们真的给了我太多的启发。
So I can't wait for more of that. I can't wait for you guys to read my book. Can't wait for more episodes. And also, next episode, I have a big surprise, a huge surprise. So if you have made it this far, I really want you to tune in because it's, it's just like the craziest thing I've ever done. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, make sure that you are following along on Spotify or Apple Podcasts wherever you are listening. It's a new year. So maybe think about leaving us a five-star review so more people can find
所以我迫不及待地想看到更多这样的时刻。我迫不及待地想让你们读我的书。迫不及待地想推出更多集。而且，下一集我有一个巨大的惊喜，一个超级巨大的惊喜。所以如果你已经听到了这里，我真的希望你继续收听，因为这，这就像是我做过的最疯狂的事情。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请确保你在Spotify或Apple Podcasts或无论你在哪里收听的平台上关注我们。这是新的一年。所以也许可以考虑给我们留下五星好评，以便更多的人能够在
us in 2025. Of course, only if you feel cool to do so, but we really do appreciate it. Share this episode on Instagram, share it with your friends, share it with your partner, share it with someone else who you think really needs to begin trusting themselves, whoever that may be. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. Happy New Year. 2%.
2025年找到我们。当然，只有在你觉得乐意这样做的时候，但我们真的非常感激。在Instagram上分享这一集，与你的朋友分享，与你的伴侣分享，与你认为真正需要开始信任自己的其他人分享，无论那是谁。直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。新年快乐。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。对我来说84年意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。在它成为疯狂的一年之前。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
那是一个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人克尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难学习法》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在其他任何地方进行这些对话其实并不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这么做，在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习法》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试造假了两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节气的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集目前没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。